it's time for our seen and unseen
segment will we expose these cultural
stories of the day or explore expose or
explore who changed that word for that
we turn to Fox News contributor Raymond
Royal onset yeah all right Ray New York
City uh budget crunch yeah and and we've
chronicled Laura in recent weeks how the
Immigrant crisis has really swamped the
city strained resources this is Mayor
Eric Adams $2 billion that we spent
already $5 billion we're going to spend
in this fiscal crisis New York don't
don't deserve this the Asylum Seekers
anyway facing billions in budget
shortfalls you would think the city
council would focus on basic Services
they just cut overtime to the cops Laura
and they're begging the federal
government for money instead they're
spending time and money on tearing down
statutes Bill allows New York City to
confront the Deep rooted legacies of
slavery colonization and systemic crimes
against humanity by mandating that the
PDC create a plan for removal we are
acknowledging and rectifying historical
wrongs histor wrong I mean the problem
here Laura is they're spending millions
of dollars to explore which statues to
take down Columbus Washington Washington
Square Park major I mean John J major
figures not only in New York but
American history they're all targeted
and here's my problem I understand
everybody should hate slavery it's a sin
but don't do war with ancient slavery do
war with present slavery let's get rid
of all ties with China that would be a
good start the biggest enslaver people
on the planet now don't go ripping
Washington now put a plaque up put it in
context put a plaque up that's enough
nor Memorial or something for the
enslave persons yeah all right Raymond
Congress is in a total tizzy over this
new Senate dress code slobs which
basically allows Senators to show up in
thongs anything they want to wear on the
floor that's ugly well this Schumer's
accommodation to his slobbiness Senator
John fedman and now things are really
getting scary I give you Senator Susan
Collins I plan to wear a bikini tomorrow
to the CER floor to do away with the
dress
code uh to me debases the
institution now she was joking I mean
was she joking good for her well looking
pretty good though yeah I mean this is
what we can expect more of though there
are no limits the only people of a dress
code now are the staff staff have to
wear ties and dresses shes who else has
to wear uh a certain dress Capital
police Capital police of course of and
so the public servants treat the public
like servants that none of this make
sense to me this is backwards they need
to reinst Institute a dress code because
dress is an expression of what's going
on inside your mind inside your heart
very you're looking very
captaining I'm
like I'm ring driving the ship I am
here's John fedman a chaos outside and
in my message to the the CEOs cosos is
you know at $74 million you know
collectively earning that you know how
many Yachts can they need you know to to
yacht to water uh ski behind it you know
I mean it's just crazy hump a leg didn't
he say hump a leg the other day yeah
yeah what is he saying he making bid
sound like but I we can't pretend that
this is normative or that that dress is
a is is acceptable it's not you're a US
senator you represent millions of people
dress like it act like it and let your
staff do the talking the outfit he
should wear maybe is a straight Jack
given the age of some of these
individuals perhaps just an adult diaper
will do now just show up with that
rightor they have hit that age you know
all right finally um you have a new a
project Raymond which I only learned
about recently is dropping this week
yeah I wait are you singing I am singing
it's a Christmas album It's called
Christmas Mary and bright viewers who
saw my Christmas shows over the year
requested this okay so we did it big 20
piece Orchestra original Arrangements
some classic carols and Jose Feliciano
he's a
preview Park the Herold angels singing
Glory to you
oh jingle bells jingle bells jingle all
the way
very we wanted to remind people of the
merry and the
[Music]
bright okay Raymond that is amazing I
cannot wait but what happened to the
orchestra is Black Tie we we just talked
about we didn't have a dress code during
the recording but on Road when we do the
tour we will and I'm going to try to get
you out on the tour Royal christmas.com
you can order it this is a great way to
bring joy and festivity are we doing any
number together we are doing a number
together and I'm giving you my first CD
no one's gotten it but you enjoy that
and just for this celebration we have to
say a special something not another
celebration we're celebrating Christmas
not the birthday torturing birthday
today and he's spending it with us isn't
that sad thank you guys should I blow it
out it doesn't blow my silk blouse well
you're the only one with the dress Cod
thank you I know what I wished and it
has something to do with Christmas and
you singing with me we'll see all right
Raymond I'm so excited Raymond is
multi-talented he's incredibly talented
I'm so proud of you I'm so excited for
you and you always bring uh Christmas
cheer wherever you go anyway Raymond
thank you thank you all right and his
album can be found at Raymond Royo
christmas.com wherever you buy music so
go check it out hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interview and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else